pour l'instant elle n'a toujours pas
renoncé à se présenter aux grandes dam
d'ailleurs de son premier adjouint qui a
une moment il avait cru en fait il y a
un an un an et demi évoqué voilà l'idée
de pas forcément se représenter et lui
s'était engouffré en fait tout de suite
dans la brèche depuis en fait non a
priori elle est à nouveau à sa tâche
enfin jusqu'à ces dernières semaines et
elle avait l'intention en tout cas de
continuer à changer Paris et en profiter
de l'élland des Jeux Olympiques pour
éventuellement retrouver un peu de
crédibilité et de et de lumière ce
voyage là en fait qui s'est passé au
pire moment puisquil s'est passé au
moment de l'assassinat de cet enseignant
en haras qui s'est passé au moment de
événement en Israël elle n'était pas là
alors elle a fait semblant en plus il a
il y a une histoire d'argent et puis y a
une histoire de comportement en fait
donc il y a l'argent effectivement avec
quel argent elle est partie pour aller
en fait voir dans ses atoles où elle a
sa fille qui se mariait donc bon a
priori elle a rendu une partie elle
aurait payé une partie du billet d'avion
s peusc un peu trouble le Conseil de
Paris qui ouvert ce matin en
fait des photos d' alorsta des photos d'
elle a postéis elle a posté quelques
photos d' où elle faisait du vélo dans
Paris et elle inauguréelle montrait des
nouvelles PIST cyclables dans Paris donc
en fait tout ça est un peu quand même
fait à minima brouillon et au maxima
enfin c'est quand même assz
insupportable y compris pour sa propre
majorité oui au alter en fait elle est
là elle pêche pile sur l'angle son point
faible en fait qui est la gestion le
problème deidalgo à Paris c'est pas tant
idéologique en fait dans les grandes
lignes de sa politique elle répond
plutôt aux aspirations de du peuple
parisien passez-moi l'expression ve plus
de vélo qui veut respirer mieux qui veut
un peu plus d'arbrees ça c'est quand
même devenu à Paris mais aussi dans les
grandes villes en France une une
aspiration assez majoritaire qui touche
vraiment au mode de vie personnel des
gens donc c'est vent les préoccupations
personnelles parfois un peu égoïste
d'ailleurs mais c'est ce que les gens
veulent et c'est ça explique d'ailleurs
la vague de nouveau maire écologiste élu
en 2020 donco senti ça depuis le début
donc elle s'incrit tout à fait dans
cette ligne et à vrai dire c'est pas
tant le procès qui lui est fait parce
que on va pas se mentir la droite serait
aux affaires à Paris elle n'aurait pas
mis plus de voitures dans la rue elle
aurait aussi fait des pistes cyclables
peut-être moins peut-être moins vite
mais elle aurait aussi fait des pistes
cyclables donc le sujet n'est pas tant
dans la gestion idéologique que dans la
gestion financière elle-même
l'augmentation de la taxe d'habitation
plus effectivement plus 50 6% pardon
excuse-moi la taxe foncière la taxe
d'habitation ayant disparu donc ça tient
à elle puisque mainant ce sont les qui
décide des taux donc plus forte
augmentation dans dans les grandes
villes françaises et puis l'endettement
donc c'estàd très concrètement ce
qu'elle fait des sous des Parisiens et
des par 7 milliards d'euros Heon pas 10
maintenant un voyage où elle est accusé
de gaspiller des dizaines de milliers
d'euros pour aller faire un voyage qui
était peut-être pas indispensable dans
la conduite de son mandat pour aller
inspecter les installations de de surf
là c'est on est pileepoil sur les procès
qui lui sont fait de manière récurrente
sur mais qu'est-ce que vous faites de
l'argent des impôts pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez besoin de les augmenter autant
et come comment qu voyons-nous les les
résultats de cette de cette gestion
financière et de cet endettement
colossal c'est pour ça que est-ce que ça
suffit à la mettre en difficulté pour se
représenter effectivement elle a montré
qu'elle avait de la ressource et puis
elle a montré qu'elle savait se
conformer justement à cette aspiration
majoritaire des parisiens avec un centre
gauche à aspiration écologiee si je le
résume très grossièrement et là elle est
difficile à déloger parce qu'elle a
quand même su occuper ce statut donc
effectivement l'angle qui pourrait la
perdre c'est celui-là c'est la gestion
c'est le fait de gaspiller l'argent oui
parce que en plus elle représente
Guillaume bah cette gauche
socialdémocrate de gouvernement elle
elle est elle est opposée à très opposé
Mlenchon voilà au moins sur sur C
ligneologique elle est du côté des
socialistes qui eux ne ne ne ne veulent
pas pactiser avec LFI et même la nupes
fagocité par par LF bon non là je pense
qu'il il y a un problème effectivement
de de de comportement personnel plus que
le voyage lui-même à il voyage il peut
se il peut se il peut s'expliquer peut
se just justifié ce qui fait très
mauvais effet et je vois mal comment
elle va se dépatouiller tout ça c'est
effectivement l'absence de clarté
d'explications parce que tout sort au
compte goutte elle sort un bout
d'explication puis après on mais en fait
il y avait ça aussi dit bah j'allais
pour visiter installation de de de sfre
après on en prend qu'elle n pas pu y
aller bon après on dit mais il y avait
les conditions météorologiques empêcher
de revenir ça pu on apprend qu' un
hélicoptère qui mis à sa
disposition voilà sur les frais au début
on dit voilà ça coûtait temps on dit non
mais elle a pris en charge une partie
rien n'est clair et quand une
communication officielle commence
à à patiner surtout à réagir chaque fois
à la la à la révélation qui suit ça
n'est ça n'est jamais bon Sigre et je
pense que ce qui lui fait du mal c'est
que c'est pas tant cette affaire là
qu'il affaiblit c'est parce qu'elle est
déjà affaiblie que cette affaire prend
voilà quelqu'un qui est position en
position de force il balaye des rumeurs
il balaye des des fausses polémiques et
cetera il reprend la main là on sent
qu'elle a cette cette difficulté à euh à
reprendre la main et voilà il y a tout
quand même tout un passif qui
s'accumulait parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle a réussi à se faire rlire bon
mais c'est vrai que la polémique sur sa
sur sa gestion sur les impôts euh même
sur son comportement ENF qu'elle même
avec même avec les vers c'est pas c'est
pas le c'est pas le c'est pas le grand
amour
euh et on voit bien que d'un côté à la
fois son opposition va sentir que c'est
le moment d'y aller non et de ils vont
pas la lâcher dessus on peut faire
confiance à R d'ti pour ne pas lâcher
anidalgo sur ce sujet-là et sur aucun
autre sujet non plus mais surtout dans
sa propre majorité euh on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'après Macron mais de sa
manière même si elle peut se représenter
elle ça sur plan il y a pas de
limitation de dans la durée des des
mandats mais euh tout le monde va
commencer à réfléchir à la prèidalgo que
ce soit dans sa propre équipe auprès de
ses alliés auprès de ceux qui vont
commencer à réfléchir des alliances à
des alliances alternatives voilà donc là
il est clairement dans un et puis
dernier point euh pour l'instant le seul
argument qu'elle a trouvé pour répondre
c'est ah ben c'est la misogynie on
s'attaque à moi parce que je suis une
femme un peu court Anne forte
augmentation de la taxe foncière est-ce
que et c'est bon à Paris c'est
particulièrement violent si je puis mer
ainsi mais c'est vrai dans quasiment
toutes les grandes villes est-ce que
c'est pas là la preuve que cette
suppression de la taxe d'habitation et
cette tentative de de remodelage des
impôts locaux par Mac c'était pas une
très bonne idée
finalement alors bonne idée ou mauvaise
idée j'en sais rien en tout cas le fait
est que d'abord c'est suppression de la
taxe d'habitation sur la résidence
principale puisque sur les résidences
secondaires ça demeure et qu'on voit
d'ailleurs au niveau local que dans
certaines communes là aussi ça a
entraîné une augmentation assez
significative de la taxe d'habitation
sur les résidences secondaires ouis et
et que bah derrière on est dans un
contexte quand même global de plutôt de
pénurie budgétaire qui conduit à ce que
les collectivités en fonction par
ailleurs des investisement elles ont pu
conduire doivent se doivent se rattraper
alors évidemment c'est particulièrement
net à Paris dans un contexte qui est
plus étendu où il y a aussi beaucoup de
propriétaires qui ont revendu leurs
biens enfin bref il y a un contexte
général j'allais dire immobilier à Paris
qui complexifie sans doute encore les
choses euh mais alors bonne ou mauvaise
idée en tout cas c'était un un une forme
d'illusion d'imaginer que ce serait une
opération neutre ça je je pense que
personne norm là pour se substitu bah
oui mais pour parti euh pour parti
seulement je je reviens juste pardon sur
la question de d'Anny dalgo et de et de
l'élection il y a quand même un
paramètre qui peut ne pas être neutre à
moyen terme c'est ce projet de
réformer applicable à Paris alors la loi
PLM pour résumé en gros c'est que euh
euh il ça consisterait à modifier cette
loi pour que le maire soit élu au
suffrage des trois grandes ville là
soitlu directement au suffrage universel
direct c'estàd qu'il y aurait un deuxème
vote la part City il y aurait plus ce
mécanisme des élections à l'échelle de
l'arrondissement puis ensuite avec la
répartition entre le Conseil de Paris et
les conseils de d'arrondissement c'est
faisable ça ah oui bien sûr c'est
faisable puisqu'on a toujours eu à Paris
Lyon et Marseille un statut particulier
après il y a un certain nombre de règles
mais qui sont assez
constitutionnellement faciles à à
respecter si j'ose dire qui s'applique
en matière électorale et donc d'avoir un
scrutin au suffrage direct ne ne pose
pas de problème constitutionnel
il y a plusieurs confusions qui se font
sur ce sujet un c'est dire on va lire
directement le maire non même si on a
une circonscription unique c'est qui
concerne l'ensemble de la ville les
électeurs éliraient des conseillers
municipaux il n'éiraient pas le maire
ils éliraient des conseillers municipaux
qui ensuite se réunirai on aurait de
votes distincts a priori tel que les
chos son pr comme c'est le cas
actuellement et deuxème point c'est de
dire que c'est la loi PLM qui a institué
ce vote par non de tout temps les
élections municipales à Paris à Lyon à
Marseille se sont déroulé dans le cadre
de circonscription d'arrondissement ce
qui a changé c'est que les pouvoirs du
maire ont été modifiés par la loi PLM
mais la circonscription électorale a
toujours été d'arrondissement avant ça
oui c'est pas la loi PLM strict sinsu
mais en revanche il y a toujours eu un
statut drogatoire appliqué en
particulier à Paris qui ensuite a été
appliqué aussi à Lyon et Marseille
moyennant des modalités donc voilà ce
mode de scrutin il peut quand même
peut-être euh changer un peu la donne et
ça serait plus démocratique
pour plus ou moins démoc plus
représentatif je veux dire
bah alors ceux qui sont les défenseurs
du système actuel vous diront non parce
qu'ils vous expliqueront que justement
le mécanisme tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
conçu garanti que chaque conseiller
d'arrondissement et donc par voie de
conséquence chaque conseiller au Conseil
de Paris puisque qu'une partie qui
ensuite monte est élu sur une base
strictement égalitaire qui justifie
qu'arrondissement par arrondissement il
y a pas le même nombre et que là il y
est une comment dire une
proportionnalité beaucoup plus fine que
par exemple pour les élections
législatives euh c'est pas tellement
plus ou moins démocratique sans doute en
tout cas ça rendra peut-être plus
immédiatement compréhensible par les les
électeurs le
maire pour
lequel voilà ils pent leur
voix Louis alter oui bah le problème du
système actuel étant que d'ailleurs
Guillaume il a consacré une page dans
dans le Figo ce matin le le typiquement
le le l'électeur de gauche du 16e
arrondissement il a aucun pouvoir parce
que de toute façon le 16e arrondissement
dans son ens votera à droite par pour
l'électeur de droite du 19e
arrondissement donc c'est un peu comme
l'élection présidentielle américaine où
à chaque fois on dit mais en fait il y a
que quelques États qui compent comme
dans l'élection à la mériie de Paris il
y a quelques arrondissements qui compent
pour faire basculer la majorité d'un
côté ou d'un autre le par contre l' faet
pervers d'aller à enfin pervers ça
dépend ce qu'on en pense mais si on a un
système classique c'estàd non
dérogatoire vous avez des majorités qui
sont plus larges plus écrasantes ça
aussi on le voit bien dans les les
graphiques du Figaro d'aujourd'hui donc
on a moins de représentativité au
conseil municipal où une majorité peut
plus facilement faire sa loi parce
qu'elle est plus écrasante donc ça veut
dire moins de débat et moins de
contradiction au sein des réunions du
conseil donc peut-être un petit peu
moins de démocratie c'est pour ça que le
débat n'est pas n'est pas noir ou blanc
et ben le débat il va continuer merci à
vous quatre merci de vos contributions
de vos éclairages de vos décryptages et
on va se retrouver bah mardi prochain
probablement avec des thèmes qui seront
pas très éloignés je suis quasiment
certain que on pararlera d'immigration
au moins et de majorité
de la droite vous avez vu aujourd'hui on
a été très sage on a pas fait très pas
tellement de mélanchons mais il pourrait
très bien réapparaître tels zau dans le
paysage bonne soirée et à la semaine
prochaine et merci à vous quatre